how much is your eq in general it's
close
mine's high i think 110
years do not never technically test
school you don't take a q test natalie
now you know you need to stop
during this episode she was on a mission
to hurt mike a little close
what do you know about low class i live
in it now
girl you can go home you can leave
the door is open natalie took it
too far not only was she disrespecting
mike
but she was disrespecting him on tv
she did this while cameras were around
which is honestly not that smart
since we want to talk about iqs here
just saying
one thing is obvious though and that's
the fact that
hurt people hurt people it's true
and we're gonna talk about it plus my
favorites
brandon and julia had a good old time
when his parents went out of town for
the night
i was excited for them but unfortunately
their bliss and freedom it lasted less
than 24 hours
the moment mrs betty and mr ron came
home
it was back to reality and they have to
be fed at the same time
every day i'm not waking up these
chickens
i already helped enough for farm i do
all what you say
i clean
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisa
i hope you're doing well let's go ahead
and get into
mike and natalie because
there is a lot to unpack here natalie
went from spending her day looking
everywhere
for the engagement ring she gave back to
mike
to insulting him worse than she probably
would
a stranger not in here
[Music]
oh it's a security to say i think
it's in the safe but i don't have a key
i mean i cannot open it
for a split second i thought she was
gonna go get a hammer
i did i thought she was gonna get a
hammer and try to crack that thing open
but thankfully she didn't their
situation is
dramatic enough right now when the
producers asked natalie
why she's desperately searching for the
ring
she responded by saying that she feels
quote
unsecure and uncomfortable without it
but based off the way she spoke to mike
when he got home
from work i don't understand why she
wants it
she doesn't seem to like anything about
him
the only conclusion i could come to
is that the ring is more about america
or being married than it is about mike
and what do we got to cut
we have streams you forgot you promised
me not to eat meat for one week
we're gonna make a pasta we'll get saute
them you want me to cook rice i don't
want you to eat pasta at night i'm sorry
rice with shrimps good rice with shrimp
mm-hmm
okay i'm gonna do stir-fry let's put on
steam i don't want you to fry it
oh my god i want you to cook on the
steam
because uh it's more healthier i'm gonna
stir fry it i don't want to eat fried
food it's not fried food it's called
stir-fry
okay you're gonna never lose fat that
that was just the beginning i'm sure
you've heard the phrase
it's not about what you say it's how you
say it
nothing is wrong with wanting your
partner to be healthy
i get that but she's speaking to him
as if she intentionally wants to hurt
his feelings
not as if she genuinely wants to help
and let's be real who is going to listen
and take advice from someone who talks
to them like that
i would either tune you out pray for you
or get defensive no more alcohol you're
not drinking alcohol
oh yeah definitely having a
i wish you beard drink water i wish you
would have a beer with me
uh-huh um yummy
it's been a long hard week when you lose
10 kilos when we talk
all right when you gain 10 kilos we'll
talk too
[Music]
she says some things are just like
hurtful
like uh she wants to work on losing
weight and stuff i mean
it just seems like it's a battle like
you know a battle you don't have to
fight
you don't have to fight this battle mike
look
i learned this in therapy good
information here
sometimes you have to ask yourself
why am i allowing someone to treat me
this way
to speak to me this way why am i
accepting this
it's slick verbal abuse natalie
might be in the wrong here but
mike has to look in the mirror too all
right
at the top you saw where she questioned
his iq
and then she called him low class let's
take a look at what happened
next the rice is done we're almost ready
and you're drunk oh my god i'm scared of
you whoa
low-class drunk man whoa how respectful
what then you are so respectful aren't
you yes sir
always calling low class like what is
this low class stuff like i don't
understand it
i mean i don't know what kind of
relationship and who was your ex-wife
she probably also some
this class uh and this all this uh i
don't strange
what class do you fit in what are you
doing
you're on a pedestal up here why do you
put yourself on a pedestal what makes
you better than anyone else
if you don't respect me it's terrible
because we cannot communicate
that's so now we know why he kicked her
out
well we don't know for sure but i'm
assuming
that's one of the reasons why subject
yourself to that
natalie might have a high iq
but her emotional intelligence
is lacking she doesn't know
how to deal with her own feelings
instead
she's putting the responsibility on mike
to change so she can feel better
about the life she chose
i know it's easier said than done but
natalie if you don't like him leave
no one has you guys attached at the hip
leave
now all of that being said the truth is
that none of us are perfect
so i definitely think she deserves some
grace
at the same time i'm not excusing her
disrespectful
behavior period you provoke mike
i think sometimes yes not in purpose but
when i feel pain i want him to
understand the amount of pain i have
by saying things or doing things and
it's like kind of circle
and i don't know how to break it when we
go far away from each other it was fun
but now i arrive and i realize he he's
like this
and i don't like how he treat me it's
not okay it's not
happy life it's a disaster
i feel like i'm going home soon i feel
the same way girl
that's probably the best thing for
everybody in this situation
all right let's move on to a fun
couple as brandon's parents we're
leaving to go away for the night
my focus was on his face and julia's
face
you could tell that they were thinking
yes
it's about to go down
and it did
[Music]
hey all right
yeah come back
he's a bad boy
[Music]
i think i enjoyed watching that a little
bit too much
i love them the next day they were back
to business as usual
on the farm and it wasn't long before
mrs betty
brought an issue to their attention you
know that we have rules in the hot tub
and we were really not happy
what's wrong it's a little cloudy
cloudy's not good
cloudy's not good did you guys wear
clothes in the hot tub
no you didn't wear clothes in the hot
tub that's not what messed up the water
okay i need to go this uh close without
but then towels to get in to get out i
know but
why wouldn't i stay same room and this
viv is out close this is fine
julia thank you thank you for asking the
question i'm sure we all
were thinking according to betty it's a
therapy pool and fabric leaves residue
that's hard to get out
while that might be true i think her
questioning them
about whether or not they had on clothes
was a segway
for her to get the answer to what she
really wanted to know
which was this the other thing you
shouldn't do in the water
do you know what that is
okay you know what that is we don't need
to talk about it not in the water okay
we didn't thank you
why you old times say like
she looked at him and she laid little
boy
how we live together i worry about this
he
started to take care of me i agree with
julia
that's what the 90 days are for right i
know brandon is attached to his parents
but by now he should be making his
future wife
a priority julia got even more
irritated that night when brandon's
parents
called him and her out to the porch for
a talk
basically they were in trouble again
brandon's dad was upset
that he isn't helping out as much as he
used to
on the farm because he's occupied with
taking julia t
in the morning his parents also brought
up the fact that julia
can start waking up earlier so she can
help more around the farm
as well i'm not waking up these chickens
i already help enough for farm i do all
what you say
i clean i'll never do this before now i
try being nice and she said i need
working more i come here marry your son
not live here and take care of your
stuff now brandon made things worse
when he told his parents that julia
makes it hard for him to leave her room
because when he tries to go she tells
him no
after that julia told everyone
that she needs some time to herself and
walked off
next week it looks like brandon is going
to have to make
the choice because julia's patience
has run out i don't want to live here
julian
i won't leave now
i try to live here but ah it's not
working
i'm done if you're not goldberg i go
russia
okay she has said that about five times
now
brandon better listen alright 90 day
fans fam
make sure you stick with e.t because as
usual
we are covering it all i'll see you next
[Music]
time
you